welcome back to New rockstars and with
She-Hulk episode 4 revealing a massive
lawsuit of She-Hulk sized proportions
everybody has been left wondering
exactly what Titania's problem might be
with the Jennifer Walters just trying to
lawyer superhuman law and peace but what
if Titania is actually right what if
Titania is actually the mcu's first
She-Hulk welcome to Rogue Theory the
show where we pitch the wildest theories
for the nerdy titles that we love my
name is Mt and growing Rogue with me
today is the master of the Wubba lubba
dub dub Arts it's Whitney van laningham
what's going on Whitney
yeah I am greatly suffering
bro no I'm actually I am doing great
today because The Queen Is Dead y'all
are here in this episode on Saturday
this is old news to you guys but it is
fresh to me
and I just want to say God God bless
everyone
except her and also the only man I know
capable of going toe-to-toe with the
Hulk himself it's everyone's favorite
super villain Jay Washington what's
going on Jay Ding Dong The Queen Is Dead
I'm sorry
I should just go along with it
you hit comments about the dream how
dare they and it's like look around the
world bill look around the world I'm
glad to be back man I'm glad and we
cannot forget about the world's greatest
magician lawyer it's my boy Brandon
Barrick what's going on Brandon oh
that's right you know I did a 23 of me
and it said I was pretty much 80 British
in my Heritage so maybe I should be the
one to say nice things here but I don't
think I'm going
uh all monarchies are bad get rid of
them
we fought really hard to throw off the
Yoke of our oppressors our forefathers
did now our forefathers were doing a lot
of oppressing themselves
we got rid of the queen a long time ago
throw off the yolks of the forefathers
oppression as well I said too many yolks
too much oppression that's all I gotta
say how dare do rocks get political I
don't want to see politics
all right roasting the queen aside even
though it might be very well deserved
let's talk about our first topic for
today oh wait I forgot I forgot I'm so
sorry one more with just one more little
one yes I just want to show off my
Princess Diana bear to all the things
listening to the podcast let me uh let
me do some closed captioning for you I'm
holding up a purple uh Princess Diana
beanie baby bear in a glass case yes
that I brought onto this podcast today
just to celebrate the queen because
guess what Diana is having her Vengeance
Diana has Vengeance today
okay that's that's it that's all I want
to say I love that bait I love a good
Beanie Baby in a in a cage you like The
Collector it's in a little collector
cage it's hilarious I am I am the mother
collector and I collect babies
right all right gang collect babies in a
film full of bees
[Laughter]
I'm really sorry Brandon you just you
just at me like that was the worst thing
a person
I was just conceptualizing like the
collector taking his his collection
sucking out their insides and filling
them full of beans
[Music]
our first topic of today first theory of
the day is that I think that Titania is
actually a Hulk in the MCU and here's
why I think this the 2008 Incredible
Hulk film had a whole room filled with
Bruce Banner's blood at the end that we
have not seen for years that your room
has disappeared who knows what happened
to it and it most likely went into the
hands of Hydra because Hydra was shield
and shield took over that whole
operation after the 2008 Incredible Hulk
film I think that Titania could be a
daughter of this Blood room from the
2008 Hulk film and that she got a little
bit of Hulk blood in her and she was
able to now have the super strength and
the ability to you know basically be a
super soldier in a way because that's
sort of what you know the the whole
purpose of the of General Ross's program
was for the Hulk in the first place is
to recreate the super soldier serum and
we know in that room full of blood that
there are different um concentrations of
gamma in each container so like there's
um 40 in one like 12 in another so like
not everyone has to become an
Abomination type looking person some
people can just literally have just
super soldier Powers so I think that
because titanium went through this
procedure and got this blood transfer
she feels like she's the first Hulk and
that um She-Hulk is the actual second
Hulk and she doesn't have the right to
be called She-Hulk and that's why she
gave um her the cease and desist to stop
a being Shield what do you guys think I
like it but I I disagree slightly the
theory is look the theory is sound
because here's why I agree with you when
we see the blood I agree that the person
trying to steal her blood is the leader
that is Samuel Stearns I think it's that
I don't think she was that I believe
we've got this world now the MCU has
been so crazy with so much stuff
happening right and again we're living
in this post snapping I'm never calling
the blip post Snap anymore
so we're in his post snapping
and like everything has happened so
people getting powers are all the things
I just think she's the mcu's Kim
Kardashian that's what I think she is
she's the influencer right she's a super
level influencer right what else would
an influencer do but sue somebody trying
to get some remember Jennifer Walter
said it herself I'm not She-Hulk I don't
even like the name and so how many times
have we heard of people oh I just
randomly blurted out something and
somebody else trademarked it and cop got
it copy written and now I own it so what
happened was Titania probably saw the
first news report that said She-Hulk and
realized it wasn't copyright it wasn't
trademarked because she's an influencer
of that level she's a super villain
influencer so it wasn't trademarked got
it trademarked and now that Jennifer
Walters is she's actually embracing the
name she can sue her for that's really
smart because like that is just like a
really good tactic just to make yourself
more popular it's like all right if I'm
like if I have the She-Hulk name then
like more people will associate me with
the elk rather than the actual hero Geo
I like that that's really smart yeah
especially if she what if she got her
powers from elective surgery that she's
been getting as part of her influencer
program you know she's getting a little
touch-ups here in there she goes to some
doctor a little bit of super soldier
Sarah yeah
yeah she's getting all that done right
and one of these injections the guy goes
like hey I got some new stuff let's try
it out let's see what it does it's gonna
lift you it's gamma radio at the same
time it's gamma radiated and she gets a
little bit of powers from me now Mt are
you saying is this like flag master flag
Smashers territory where she's getting
the Hulk blood but not changing
physically at all like yeah because of
whatever her dosage was it's not
changing her body yeah like Emile
Blonsky first round yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah I think the power broker
is out here you know trying to make
moves since she lost all of her super
soldier serum in Captain America
um boy not Captain America uh Falcon
Winter Soldier no you said it right
Captain America Captain America soldier
yeah
my brain do it was good
um but I think that the power broker
really wants to be able to broke power
and that this blood is out here and she
probably finds this whole Lab of blood
and she's like all right since I don't
got the the good stuff I'll just try to
make super soldiers with uh Bruce's
blood and try not to make hulks because
it's very easy to make hulks with gamma
radiation
um so I don't know
um I just think it's I think the power
broker is out here making moves I think
Sharon Carter needs to make her money
she does not like the US government she
doesn't care about
um whether or not power goes into the
wrong hands because she's just chilling
madrapore with all these criminals
um so I think I don't know I feel like
it is likely that you know she could
possibly be working with these uh I
don't know influencers to be like you
want some Powers why not make you look
real cool on Instagram do you think the
power broker could have transformed
Titania in a way as like a distraction
or to create just like chaos in a way
titanium is Titania aware Sharon Sharon
Carter is as the power broke she's just
about chaos she want to bring it all
look again after the snapping never sang
blimp remember it's why do you think you
have the GRC why do you think you have
the events of with the flag Smashers
everything is out of whack nothing is
there are some parts of life that seem
normal but they're not normal and
because again Sharon Carter has that
insight into the back the back door of
things that are really happening she
like yo I can get paid off all this
y'all left me y'all let me go after the
winners the uh Captain America too y'all
didn't care about me no more so now when
she comes back she wants everything
Titania out here like look there's a
whole there's an Avengers con Mt and
Whitney there's an adventure's top what
made you think an influencer wouldn't be
present okay true
true there's people at Adventures con
dressed up as Loki who to them is the
man who tried to invade Earth and
they're dressed up as Loki yeah aliens
into Manhattan okay that's literally
like dressing up like Osama dress up but
that's not that's not cool
Thanos like froyo shop in New Asgard
like they are like none of this [ __ ]
this is just murder worship this is
worse than all the like white girls who
have True Crime oh my gosh that are just
like oh my God Ted Bundy was not this is
like that this is like that but worse
it's like that it was messed up but I
feel like that they should have said
that in the movies it's just like oh
would you say a white girl and a true
grandpa True Crime because listen look
I'm glad Whitney said it white women
love True Crime podcasts for some reason
we do it's part of my people's culture I
don't know what to tell you
we commit the most True Crime so that's
why
we're always learning always studying
always getting better that's hilarious
always getting better like literally
like I used to date a girl that like all
she did was listen to True Crime
podcasts and like it gave me fear for
living life because I just know all
about these murders that happened in the
dead of night I'm like come on man I I
don't want that to be me I no I will
fully admit to being one of these people
because when I was a very when I was a
child my parents got divorced and my mom
and I we both like couldn't sleep
because we had horrific anxiety after
the divorce and so we started watching
Court TV together and uh Unsolved
Mysteries a little uh you know a little
a little documentary on Michael swongo
here and there uh and and yeah and I
don't know why it was like so comforting
for some reason so yeah I don't know
nothing like a good unsolved mystery
it's true I'm a sick little freak I also
love X-Files like [ __ ] like that like
any any like Bigfoot [ __ ] mystery [ __ ]
I'm into now empty you brought up the
power broker right uh with Titania do
you think there's any way that Titania
because of the timeline and how this all
is kind of shaking out could she be
related to the ten rings at all
I do you think like maybe she could be a
tool of the ten Rings now that uh we've
got like uh Xiang xi's sister XI Ling I
believe in charge of the ten Rings is
this is this her trying to create some
chaos uh in the world that would make a
lot of sense
um and like I could see the 10 Rings
being involved for sure like I think
that titanium like are we really this is
a stupid idea but like like Titania
wears a lot of jewelry like what if
she's like for some reason has like
super powered jewelry like it's like 10
Rings technology it's like ah this one
I'm getting my superpowers what did I
say a couple episodes ago the ten Rings
the bracelets all of that a part of an
Intergalactic jewelry set I remember I
said that on this show
you did say that Jay you did it's just
the game pretty pretty princess
it's just pretty pretty princess but
like I know I can totally see the the
ten Rings like wanting to get into the
the super powered enhanced person
business by using people as Weapons like
we sort of um saw
um Jillian in Avengers in Avengers 3
Iron Man 3 with the experiments program
and like him claiming to be the Mander
and all that stuff so like I can see the
tenorings sort of looking at killing and
being like all right you pretended to be
us with all this superhuman enhanced
people let's actually do that now and
make titanium like make like superhuman
people what would razor fist be then
because like you had raisins like you
gotta do the arm up and was like hey bro
this gonna hurt a little bit and put a
high-end blade
I was like I don't hurt a little [ __ ]
now wiping is gonna be so much harder
yeah brother because I'm sort of hey at
least they gave him one good arm in the
comics he's got two swords for arms
that's even worse at least he's got a
wiping that means he has an automated
three three seashells he has the first
version of the Demolition Man three
seashells but they automated he ain't
gotta use it that's a man who gets a
bidet ladies 100 that's amazing that's a
man it's a man with a bidet
um I guess that like my the something
that I just really want to bring it
bring it back to is something that Mt
said when he was first describing this
whole Titania situation which is that
she is a daughter of the blood room and
I just think that now she should form a
[ __ ] metal
I'm sorry Titania and the daughters of
the blood oh is like so cool honestly I
think that's a good title for a Disney
Plus show right there titanium it's like
a really a really solid just like
anti-fascist black metal band would be
oh perfect and she plays at the she
plays at a whiskey go go whiskey go go
out here in L.A oh yeah like that yeah I
mean it would make sense as an
influencer that she puts out an album at
some point now it is time for judgment
because now with this theory that I
think that Titania being one of the
mcu's first she-hulks like the actual
first shield what do you guys think do
you guys think this theory is rogus
bogus or middle August to start with you
Whitney I'm actually gonna give it a
bogus because
I don't think that getting blood makes
her a She-Hulk okay I think that that
just makes her a round one Emile Blonsky
right so like that's I don't think that
he was a Hulk when he got the super
soldier serum because like Cap's not a
haul right like he's not a Hulk a bunch
of guys have gotten it and they're not
hooks just because she took a little
botulinum toxin a little gamma radiation
put it in those put it in those little
cheeks doesn't make her a hook and if
she wants to claim she is
girl you're gonna have to come down and
fight Megan this down right
I like how it's not Shield it's back in
the style you have to fight Megan not
not Jennifer yeah I mean well you know
She-Hulk would kill for Megan Megan's
got a kill for her it's only fair it's
just transitive property of The
Sisterhood of the Traveling lawyer pants
traveling twerking pants I don't know
yeah sister of the twerking pants let's
get it okay I'll take that what do you
think Brendan I'm gonna give this one
I'll give it like an oh guess leaming
rogus only because they do love to have
like these parallels on these types of
shows so like the Revelation that she is
somehow in the Hulk family as a daughter
of the blood room would make a little
bit of sense
I I don't know I'm skeptical but it
would be an explanation of her powers if
they're not gonna say like oh she's a
mutant right uh so maybe this could pan
out it's Rogue enough that it just might
work empty I'll take it August I think
on August is fair bogus is fair uh
what's going on what you think uh Jay so
I'm gonna take my thick ass thumb and go
from August it's a bit bogey it's like
Whitney okay because
mutation is a word now
right true mutation is a word so it
would not surprise me if she is that you
know she said yeah the daughters of the
blood room again Disney plus make that a
damn show that is a great time
but I think like again I think she's
just a high level influencer that's a
mutant I think she's a mutant influencer
and again the MCU again this in this era
we've played into a lot of stuff that's
happening now social media is a thing
all these things
Seahawks on a dating app bro like she's
yeah that's on a dating app so an
influencer being that a type of
influencer and it just happens to be a
mutant again that word mutation changed
the game in the last episode of Miss
Marvel oh [ __ ] you know what I just
thought guys I
I just want to see you tomorrow I want
to see the meals it's just it's Ja Rule
and Titania and they are planning the
fire Festival I need to see what the MCU
would do it he would do it like I feel
like it's gonna be without you that's
a pretty good job
but no I will take this these are all
great assessments I I think that it's
it's I feel like the whole mutant angle
especially since um Miss Marvel had uh
Titania in it as like an Easter egg and
like you and now that we know that uh
Miss Marvel is a mutant herself it would
not surprise me to see if Titania was a
mutant too because like it just
continued that trend of introducing more
mutants into the MCU so no I I think I
think I like that theory a lot and uh I
think it's much better than my bogus
Theory I'm giving myself a focus no it
was a fun Theory um
oh so nobody so nobody so nobody
believes me okay you know what I'm gonna
[ __ ] just lose
but up next Brandon has a really fun
theory about the Thunderbolts which I
cannot wait to hear but first be sure to
head on over to new rockstarsmerch.com
where you can grab our newest latest
Obsession merch Lady Justice inspired by
the She-Hulk series because she's a lady
doing the Justice this limited edition
shirt will not be available for long and
when you purchase it you unlock the
ability to get a custom shout out that
will appear on our inside Marvel after
show hosted by me Mt Eric Voss and
Jessica Clemens so check out our latest
Obsession shirts and all of our other
merch options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com today and we also
want to thank our partners at Blue chew
for sponsoring Rogue Theory this week
Bluetooth can help give you an extra bit
of confidence when it matters most
Bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you could take them anytime day
or night afternoon dusk Twilight I don't
know so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises and the
process is super simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and they've
got a lot and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days and the best part wait is that does
oh does Jay have a salute you right now
Jay is ready Jay is ready night's day
dusk anytime oh yes and the best part
it's all done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line in the pharmacy
which is the worst Bluetooth tablets are
made in the USA so USA all day and
prepared and shipped direct to your door
in a discrete package so it makes this
December a December to remember for you
and your partner and give yourself that
boost of confidence and have and head on
over to bluetooth.com and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
Bluetooth free when you use our promo
code Rogue at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code Rogue to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring
this podcast but now Brandon has our
second topic for today take it away
Brandon okay so here you go folks you
know it's Disney plus d23 is happening
right now we're recording this early so
we don't know what's going on so this
may have come true already uh that's how
much I believe in this Theory okay One
Thing Marvel loves to do is like put a
title on the board right and as we get
closer to it they change the title
because they were like faking us out
they were holding us out they did it uh
they did it with
um uh Captain America Civil War was
originally like Captain America Society
right and then they changed it oh it was
I didn't know that oh yeah yeah it was
serpent Society for a little while yeah
right now they've got the Thunderbolts
film lined up to end phase five okay and
we're you know we're not too far off
from that it's it's not too long away we
haven't heard much about the film or or
like how it's going to shake out we have
some ideas who's gonna be in it right
probably us agent John Walker's gonna be
in it Johnny mayonnaise himself we're
probably gonna have Yelena in it in some
form or another right but what I think
the big key here is that
the title of this film is going to be
changed from just Thunderbolts to
Thunderbolts versus Young Avengers okay
and I think the reason for that is
there's no more Avengers anymore they're
gone they don't exist anymore they act
like they're still there but they're not
really right Stephen Strange he's
chasing strange in the dark dimensions
[Laughter]
with me
give me that a woman showed up on the
street
give me that hole in the universe and
the man followed her into it the guys
insane the love of his life left him and
not just for him normally for black dude
she ain't never coming back so he got
enough
like Steven Strait was like if she ain't
married to the other white doctor he'd
be like well Christine you know there's
a shot he saw the black dude he was like
I never can do this back
I lost her forever in every Multiverse
there's no magic that'll fix that
problem and honestly I would Chase
Charlize Theron into a pit full of
vipers if she asked me to I mean but
he's gone right uh Hulk's gone he's he's
left the planet he's out of here he's
gone uh you got dead Avengers all over
the place
Hawkeye Hawkeye can't hear anything
Hawkeye can't hear nothing right
I can't hear nothing
Vision Vision has died for the 100th
time and now you got white Vision
running around like
there's no Avengers anymore
okay the Young Avengers are gonna form
themselves because they're going to
realize oh there's no one here to stop
these problems because the Thunderbolts
I think they're gonna do like a Dark
Avenger style like the government is
going to back the Thunderbolts I don't
even think they're going to call them
the Thunderbolts we'll see about that
but I think the government now right is
like the dodc and sword and they're
gonna back the Thunderbolts they're
gonna put them in place because as you
as we were talking about earlier right
the world's different now the snapping
has happened okay Everything's changed
and now the government realizes like we
can't play nice anymore we got to get
down and dirty we gotta have these like
covert Ops things so they're gonna form
the Thunderbolts uh and it's good this
film is gonna be like Thunderbolts
versus Young Avengers and the Young
Avengers are going to be privatized you
know what I mean they're going to work
on their own they're going to come out
there maybe pepper pots is going to show
up and throw a couple mil their way to
help her out help them out like Tony
would have right because Tony paid for
the Avengers for damage control Tony
made damage control yeah and now that
pepper pots is like in in charge of goo
currency
she actually has a dildo on her site
already called the Thunderbolts uh and
it's made out of Christmas
Amethyst in you all right
but yeah that's basically my theory that
this Thunderbolts film is going to be
Thunderbolts versus the Young Avengers
they're gonna be who it's gonna be up
against and that's how they're going to
form the Young Avengers and they're
gonna form themselves I'd like to go
first if I may I love that theory my
only question is who gets the kids
Wanda's kids
who goes and gets the boys because
that's the only oh like a different
dimension or something because that's
that's gonna be like the main unless his
vision somehow or whatever because he's
part you know he's he's still white
vision is still yes he's still of the
Mind Stone and he's the reconfiguration
of the body but he may have that Essence
right of Wanda in him who knows or
whatever but Elena coming together being
that Kate Bishop being the person
against her and everybody in the Young
Avengers but who gets the boys because
they're not alive in they weren't alive
ever right well white vision isn't the
dad but this is his opportunity to be
the daddy man he can come in with his uh
with his Polo tucked in yeah
go get custody of those kids
who goes and gets them because if I love
the idea of the two the Thunderbolts
being the MCU Suicide Squad I love that
right basically that's what it is right
but in order to get the Young Avengers
together and they come together like yo
who do I know can help me with this who
do I know we need somebody else who else
can do it somebody has to know about the
boys to get the boys in another
dimension I I like your idea that it
could be white Vision right like white
Vision because he got some of the right
ways from Scarlet Vision before he he
was killed for the 100th time I like the
idea of he's like I gotta get these kids
but like because he's white vision and
he has no like morality or whatever he
just shows up at cometage he basically
grabs Wong by the neck and he's like
open a portal and bring these boys in
From Another Dimension or he goes and
gets America shot
America doesn't bring him back America
doesn't or I'm gonna chop I'm gonna chop
Wong's head off because I'm white vision
and I don't care oh or because we have
a custody of those ideas
there'll be an episode of She-Hulk
called not without my face
[Laughter]
suing for custody of his fake sons from
a different dimension wow that would be
kind of a crazy imagine like white
Vision versus Wanda like after the
events of multiversal Madness like my
wife is no longer fit to raise by sons
yeah eight three eight three eight
Wonder was divorced man there was no
pain in that house she was divorced as
hell
she's living in a palace that white fit
that Vision built and she got it in the
divorce she got the kids she got the
house Vision in the 838 he's out there
he's drinking his ass off he's a mess oh
he's living in an apartment complex yeah
that Vision has an apartment
where's my babies
my density has increased in my weight
just in a motel just like life in
shambles yeah
Vision a38 vision is dating a 22 year
old oh no talk to her because she's dumb
as hell television just picked up
Leonardo DiCaprio's ex-girlfriend
it would be sort of in line with the
comics if we're modeling uh Wonder Man
off of a Leonardo DiCaprio it's like
being out of DiCaprio Matrix in my brain
I cannot date anyone on under 20 over
25. I don't know what I'm talking about
but no it would literally perfect yeah
vision original use America Chavez to
get the kids in yeah she
yeah she'll portal and get
that I would love the idea kids the kids
split sides like one of them go with the
Young Avengers
a little twin fight like who would be
the one most likely to be on the
Thunderbolts though
Tommy
I think yeah
Tommy yeah yeah it's Tommy Tommy's the
more Troublemaker of the two that's just
how that's just how boys name Tommy
but all right all right let's let's talk
about this let's judge this Theory now
like this theory of the Thunderbolts
reversing the Young Avengers in the
Thunderbolt series what do you guys
think about this is it rogus bogus or
August well yes okay we got one rocus
from Wendy what you think Jake oh yes
Rogue is indeed Imma have to give it a
third brogus because I love the idea oh
baby
go head to head because of their new
friendship in Hawkeye like they're on
the elevator bonding yeah I know and
like they already fought a little bit in
Hawkeye so like I'd want to see round
two with their own teams just to see how
like how well they manage their teams
together I was gonna say I also love I
love the twin split too man I love the
idea because like both the twins on the
same team that's too powerful that's too
powerful two twins two powerful yeah you
got it
you got you got us agent out here trying
to still remember his dead black friend
like who got kicked into a Lamar man
Lamar got kicked into a b
like
you
Crossroads so like he lost his only
black friend because clearly he had no
other black friends so that's why he's
snapped up so hard he was like I only
had one and you and that's when he
snapped like if you see no other black
people around John Walker he was like I
had one black friend he
he was teaching you got sweet potato pie
and you took them away
other black person I knew broke my arm
no I really do want to see the
Thunderbolts versus the Young Avengers
so badly like please make it happen
Kevin please I needed my system and then
you get Cameron from uh Miss Marvel
because the sun okay
he's Mark clandestine or whatever they
are he's got ability so everybody that
has powers that were small side
characters come together now in this
bigger film
right okay I can see a red dagger as
well
yeah but yeah no this I I this this like
uh Thunderbolts versus Young Avengers
project would be so huge basically Civil
War 1.5 I'd be all about it so uh let's
get it marble let's get it I hopefully I
hope we get dark blue
Tech
and I've seen some [ __ ] there man I've
seen [ __ ] in California I hooked up with
several other women I don't need you
anymore
Kamala you've you and the kid I don't
love me no more I'm here now it's in
cell Bruno
but it's now it is time for our Rogue
question are you guys ready for this one
because it is d23 this weekend where
Disney is revealing some of their
upcoming projects for Star Wars Marvel
and other IP under their collection and
we're recording this before a lot of
their big announcements so take this
opportunity to pitch me your rogus dream
project that you wish Disney would
announce well I wish they would do now
that they own Fox okay there's a little
part of fox that I would love Disney to
get into and mix some things together I
want to see a crossover where you have
some Marvel characters go up against
like alien and Predator like the
xenomorph and the Predator do one of
those crossovers I think that would be
like so much fun like a random thing
like maybe have some of the space Marvel
characters maybe if it's like the
Guardians of the Galaxy or someone out
there in space Thor Thor going against
like the predator or something like that
would be a lot of fun I'll be super dope
I love like the Predator universe and
the alien Universe I wanted to cross
over I like when they do the Crossovers
yeah that's what I want it's some sort
of weird crossover no uh Marvel did a
series of uh covers with a alien and
like I think that those are the coolest
covers ever like there's a Captain
Marvel being hunted by a xenomorph so
like I want to see that in real life for
sure like that'd be super dope honestly
that would make that would have made
Boba Fett like 1000 more
oh
the worst heartburn of all time what do
you guys think oh I don't know if I can
beat that one I would like to see X-Men
evolution oh oh my God yo I would love
like it's like we'd be like a
continuation of the series no like a
like a new like this is their way live
action yeah this is their way to
introduce the expert okay because now we
have to see the Because by time we get
them everybody keeps forgetting the
timeline right or we're we're currently
in our timeline 2022 the MCU is in 2025
right so the evolution of we think X-Men
evolution we think the high school but
this is how you start introducing them
and getting to know everybody and of
course they fight each other and even
while they fighting each other to the
backdrop of stuff that's going on in the
current MCU so like something might have
happened in wakanda you're like yo
what's going on there nothing get your
punk ass up like you know Scott's being
bullied as always you know what I'm
saying Logan is just drunk
[Laughter]
get away from me like just mad but you
have that little and then you might have
a few younger people who grow up to be
the older X-Men by time we get the X-Men
itself movie I would love X-Men
evolution bro like the Disney plus
series as a Disney plus series yo like
literally Disney plus subscriptions
would Skyrocket if that happened
Skyrocket absolutely Skyrocket so I'm a
big fan uh what you got Whitney okay I
want to make two suggestions because one
of them is serious
I want it I want to make I want to see
uh This Is Spinal tap style behind the
scenes documentary of the hip band power
line
oh my God yeah like a full-on like
Christopher Guest and Eugene Levy style
docu like mockumentary power line I
would love that but in all seriousness
Disney I want you to unfold cancel the
owl house and give me nine more seasons
of gay witches because that's all I care
about that is all I give a [ __ ] about if
you uncancel that [ __ ] I will uncancel
you from my phone
I will stop burning the Effigies every
night
no uh I hate when a good show gets
canceled and Owl House is a really good
show I haven't watched all of it yet I'm
on season one still but it's a great
show so
um I co-signed that hardcore but these
were all great great answers but I'm
gonna have to give the the award for
rogue question winner of the day to
Brandon for that alien idea because that
is such a great idea
I love a good alien alien crossover
bring me my xenomorph bring me my
xenobarfs let's make it happen bring me
my Zeno make sure they're on their
leashes
yes keep them on relationships please
please all of the Queen's dead
nice guys hey that's my that's my queen
you know what I'm talking about
but that is it for this crazy episode of
Rogue Theory thanks to our amazing guest
Whitney van laningham jay Washington and
Brandon Barrick support them first of
all follow them wherever they are on
Twitter they're amazing people they
tweet amazing things up so go support
them wherever they are and support our
Channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at New
rockstarsmerch.com and if you've got
some thoughts on some of our Rogue
theories you can share them on our
Discord so if you're over 18 search for
new rockstars Discord server and just
join the conversation and you can follow
me at masterton if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] you can follow me
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
YouTube see you guys next time we love
you and be safe goodbye bye
[Music]
thank you